[Music]
all right up next is sam from tampa hey
sam welcome to the show
hey thank you guys very much for taking
my call
so i have a question in regards to whole
life insurance
insurance
and i've been listening to the show for
several years now i'm a big fan and uh
dave i know your opinion
on our whole life versus term
however
i recently got married nine months ago
and my wife
she's 27 years old
her grandparents purchased a whole life
insurance policy for her when she was
born so they've been panel it for 27
years now
and essentially
her grandparents are transferring it to
me and so i can either surrender it now
and get a basically about five thousand
dollars
or i can continue to pay in about
eighteen dollars a month um and you know
get the i think it's uh forty thousand
dollars worth of life insurance coverage
and it's a savings type uh account where
it accumulates and we can surrender at
any time so
um i i know i would never buy a whole
life
insurance policy based on your guidance
i would only get the term however
in this case i'm you know getting it's
being transferred to me so i'm trying to
find out uh you know what your advice is
on this yeah that's a great question sam
so
i i would actually my husband we had
kind of a similar
situation from other family
members kind of thing
and kind of exactly basically the same
thing had a policy um for us as well and
we immediately just cashed it out and
opened a mutual fund and put that money
in there because it's going to grow
so much more the growth is going to be
insane especially since you guys are so
young um in something like a mutual fund
versus sitting in that whole life
account and then you guys just go get
term insurance um for you and your wife
and so you're keeping your investments
and your savings separate from your
insurance but i would
um i would circle back are her are her
grandparents still living
her grand parents are still living and i
just haven't gotten a chance to talk to
the financial advisor to get the details
on it no no no don't you don't you don't
need to have a discussion but it's not a
financial advisor it's a it's an
insurance agent but i would financial
advisors don't sell this crap
but i would wrap around to the
grandparents though and just out of just
i think honoring them and what they've
done because their heart in it was
really good for her right hey we're
gonna set this up for you
and all of that and just wrap back
around and say hey you know
the gratitude that you guys have that
you know you got five thousand dollars
and that's amazing and how thankful you
are but hey here's our plan going
forward just so you're aware
we're going to get you know our life
insurance over here and we're actually
going to put this in an investment we're
really excited about it because we hope
to use it for a down payment on a home
down the road or whatever it is but at
least giving them that dignity dignity
and honor um
of letting them know what you're doing
with it because i think that that's i
mean it's a gift a huge gift which is
very kind yeah
if you want to depending on how touchy
this is with the with the grandparents
you could sit down with a smart investor
pro and open roth ira
and just put the money into the roth
into good mutual funds and then you can
show grandpa hey grandpa this y'all get
a great thing for her thank you so much
or she could say this even better than
you seeing it and we met with our
financial advisor and we decided to put
it in into an investment and so we moved
it over to there but boy you gave us a
great jump start on there and here's
what this mutual fund's done for the
last 70 years it's averaged you know
11.2 percent for the last 70 years it's
really exciting and you can show that
you didn't go to vegas with the money or
buy a lotto ticket which is your gran
her grandfather's fear that you're an
idiot right and so you just kind of got
to prove that you had a plan
and the more she says grandpa thank you
for this and we talked about it we met
with our financial advisor you don't
need financial advice from their
financial advisor because they're not a
real financial advisor real financial
advisors don't sell cash value insurance
only insurance people sell them
financial advisors only believe in term